you
okay we're ready to go a group of 32 for
a 300 blitz tournament it appears I'll
get juicy ketchup in round one yes Wow
haven't played in a bit blitz ok
nimzo-indian these six I'll I'll go I'll
go alpha zero style
ooh it's a thinker for the for JK oh are
you are you are you listening to my
commentary hmm
alright I'll tell you what I'm gonna put
my knight here and I'm gonna try and
gain some some Tempe against this Bishop
let's see oh alright what would alpha
zero do here that is my train of thought
but what would Alf oh it Alf do probably
a three see what the bishop wants to do
choose to take or back up you took now
we go alpha 0 style space didn't
you play a standard game kind of like
this okay
I don't know huh well I think I may want
to take right now I don't want to see
this
let's take and
this night is a big dummy this structure
this I won't be able to challenge this
pawn so I need to
I definitely have to get this night
doing something different so Oh actually
I guess I guess what black is
considering a capture like this so that
c5 is still available though this could
hurt pretty fast
rookie 1 e 6 I really crack open the
kingside ok so we start with this this
Bishop is a kind of a dummy
[Music]
just look for night f1 night III
probably right now I don't see any
fantastic square the night can make use
of on the queenside
and from here do I play with h4 right
now I'll tell you what I'll go with h4
because maybe I want to go like this
route instead of this route so I'm not
putting a blindfold over my bisshop oh
you know I'll go one step further I like
having this clamped down on the
structure and I'll do this right now cuz
I don't want to allow this Bishop to
exchange itself off and do I want to do
this I give up this square thing I might
want to just fight this is this is
blacks one really good square on c4
let's
this I don't think I have to rush I
think I'll play b3 if Knight here
was really tempted to do this but before
there's this and then eighty-five black
starts to get some really nice
counterplay I believe on the queenside I
don't like that after 95 b3 my queen has
a responsibility but oh okay now that's
interesting black is fighting for the g5
square huh could I could I get away with
the sacrifice
let's just make a developing move I'm
not sure yeah you know maybe I do
maybe I do this or here and then here
and then Queen d2 I'll have to be
careful of this oh that's a bad Mouse
lip after all that talk okay I gave up a
wonderful squared to the night
just try and offset them with my rook I
want to play b3 it's gonna be a bit
uncomfortable now this this is one pesky
piece okay and take the like that and go
here alright and yeah I'm gonna
reposition I think I like how I'm going
about this reposition so far I like the
decision to take with the bishop and
keep my knight around I don't want to
trade too many minor pieces I'm not sure
why can't really express my train of
thought
well okay actually maybe I should have
considered this and then here so I have
some space in the center and now I'm
telling ya I'm trying to I'm trying to
implement alpha zero stuff whenever
possible
okay night what do you got brewing let's
can test a file ooh you know what I did
I realized that there's a an
intersection square and C 1 so that move
I'm gonna duck no no I could take here
though I think this is winning I'll make
use of this file first
no no quick double and then we go with
h6 oh I missed that that's even a move I
got a I got a hurry up forgetting it's
blitz winning upon though I'm on the
rook I had something better I have a
passer hey this bishop is still dead
he's a dead man
take the night throw a queen here it
knows that mate it's very close to me
check our Oni and push and I could do
something like that be a little fancy so
close to mate be careful okay they
resigned
well they weren't gonna test my mouse
I'm glad you didn't Oh tell them the
first game is tough
okay yeah that pond play you know space
invaders
uh what'd I miss anything yeah I missed
some stuff axiom Fox 37 months in a row
you add nice to see you again
enjoy the analysis thanks man okay let's
get a move in here Clint thank you for
the resub five months in a row and air X
Kemp what's going on thank you for the
sub with twitch prime so we're gonna
have a black mare Deemer okay let's
focus on the game now yeah got people in
the chat trying to distract me all right
we're gonna I don't think I have maybe
against a computer I've accepted I don't
like doing it against these humans I've
played this many times but my experience
says that it's foolish because f3 you
know there's just all this space white
ends up getting alright when I see that
move I think where is the King in a
castle going King side is kind of
weakening in Queen side now this is a
something I can maybe bite at one day
that said I think in all scenarios my
knight belongs here so let's let's get
there the way I want to strike at this
pawn actually I could consider a five
hour c5 let's start with the b6 I was
thinking about doing this a 6 b5 wants
to be a bit more direct with getting my
pieces involved I'm gonna go here I'm
anticipating a knight will drop in here
and I never want to take it because the
rook has helped the structure has helped
and yeah so I just keep the bishop kind
of tucked away and if a knight drops
there I maintain the tension
I want to get in see 5 and then Queen
here don't want to allow night be 5 and
quite to coordinate here so I gotta get
c5 in my structure might be a bit messed
up after some captures how do I want to
capture exactly
I'm gonna actually take with the pawn I
know these guys are split but I don't I
don't want to allow this knight to
exchange himself off yeah I mean he
could hmm
I guess I just want to keep some pieces
on the board Queen c7 rook on the D file
so if this Knight does move I get to
improve a piece okay so this is this is
fun
and I definitely want to go with the
Queen not the rook because this is
another idea I don't want the Queen
breathing down towards my King I do have
there are these two bishops pointing
near my king but I should be able to
defend that I'm leaning more towards
rook here definitely take with the
master defender of my Kings side knight
on f6 I have this secure I was going to
say I go with this rook so that this
square is opened up this is now hit but
I couldn't start pushing no let's look
for something direct let's go with this
if I go like that then this b6 square is
a bit sensitive so we'll defend with the
rook I didn't like demoting my knight to
offset this guy I'm thinking more of
forward moves with this guy so I have
this in my back pocket I have this in my
back pocket I'm not yet thinking about a
flight square it's still this this kind
of stuff scares me really asking for
trouble maybe in some lines with Queen
h4 okay Bishop there so I have less fear
of some King side attack if I go like
this a six is gonna drop this Knight is
unprotected I could improve the night I
think I like doing this and
maybe if there's less pressure here my
bishop can improve so I'm taking two
steps but I improve each minor piece of
rank okay so less pressure here maybe my
bishop can do something fancy so there's
a competition over c3 and I guess I
could
chopper Oney no no no no no I forgot I
have something even better
this one's juicy that's a queen I'm
coordinating an e3 I was really quick he
see that that positional sense in me
said I'll go for the structure no go for
the queen who cares about doubled see
pawns
all right man this one's flying by 12
minutes in Darkseid ha nice name
that's a bit slow catching on to that
one Darkseid one this isn't our first
time playing okay probably a lot of
bullet huh or hyper seems to be bullet
okay uh I'm gonna just cancel out any
Bishop g4 stuff you know play with two
pawns in the center Knights on on good
squares and I want to go here yeah let's
see h6 is fine h6 I dropped back and
then I'll be excited about Queen d2 it's
tempo
okay let's do this now and so h6 is
simply ruled out I'm staying reflexive
or reflexive oh I'm staying flexible
with my king bishop
is what I meant to say King h8 is a bit
mysterious well I'm
during Bishop e2 is the plan here and
then if I tell you what I want to see
what black does here first I feel like I
could okay
keep that tension and get some more
development in this exchange cannot be
avoided if Bishop takes Bishop the Queen
recaptures queen here to challenge my
queen this could be a sensitive point I
am I am better in this position black is
under developing do I want to go into an
opposite sides castles position I'm
gonna say no it's not necessary and I
could just maintain an advantage due to
my son essential pawn presence no reason
to get into some space or some race I
should say what to do here well let's
let's start by putting up a rook in the
center what I do not want to do is take
here and help this rook out I do not
want to justify the rook GA move so I'm
just and I'm just not taking there so I
get to recapture and improve think right
around this point I want to take the
bishop yeah
swith check
and I don't know what's not started mate
see what happens
9 f7 looking pretty serious this is not
saving ok let's start to coordinate on
some squares this is this is a juicy
square on e6 do I do I push here and
then take a dive in
I'm gonna do this it looks a little bit
weird to put a blindfold over my bishop
I gotta catch up
timewise
let's go let's go I want it I want to do
this take with the bishop and throw a
punch of the Queen I really want to jump
in here and Knight right behind that
pawn and from here just double up and
really really try and highlight that
this this pawn is half dead
okay well let's jump in we're taking
with the pawn so
as much of an issue with this oh why is
that played oh I have this this is even
better take upon and win on I think it's
a full ruck now let's take not getting
the you're not getting the night back
it's that about take on pass on okay
let's just go here thirty three seconds
I'm not missing anything let's just get
back to a central post be a trading
machine is all just trade off the strong
pieces that Bishop is a monster pointing
at the heart however indirect it may be
centralized maybe I should have captured
first okay we'll do it now I got a
passer to improve my night
many many ways to go about it
many backward moves here by my opponent
just gonna glue everything in there
just stay defended be a be a trading
machine hit the rook stop Knight b6 push
this pawn to stop ya from one time won't
be an issue 20 is there's enough gas in
the tank okay let's that's just exchange
should be made in a couple okay
night away okay let's check and this is
gonna be checkmate in the corner all
right so three games in big yarol is in
first he has five games stumbled in
round one forty nine total players now
flash Gruden thank you for the resub
Tier one seven months in a row and you
add hope you're having a nice day I am
well it's a night for me now and it's
12:01 a.m. Friday for me okay
let's see what Raymond has
[Music]
okay let's let's try and fight fight off
that bishop
and ready where do I want to go with
this guy I go here I do have to be
careful of a fork but I'm prepared to
back up if that's maybe an issue let's
go with the night here I want to keep
some direct sight over e5 okay let's go
here I guess they're gearing up for that
I don't think I have to budge I'll wait
for this capture and I'll improve my
night Oh Kyler they're releasing
pressure here let's play in the center
okay I'm gonna keep going
mm-hmm keep driving driving forward okay
what do I do here
take
what do I have here not a lot of time I
could push well I want to always push
yeah let's let's let's push ooh let's
take and then open up my bishops eyes I
have this let's look at something more
forceful first this might be even
juicier
I think these light squares are
officially cooked for black I'm gonna
hop in here with the fork you have to
take and then Queen on e6 wow she is
massive here kind of may be held off
well let's let's make sure my bishops
eyes are open so I think it wasn't it
the last game I was pointing out that
this could be a problem mm-hmm well I
feel like their King is going to suffer
if I get my knight here it's basically
checkmate
that's kind of how I see it maybe I
should have done this first okay let's
go here I'm anticipating the dark square
bishop s' will be often the king is
going to be that much more vulnerable
maybe I went with the wrong rook f2
could become sensitive if there's one
square that could become sensitive that
would be it yeah I wish I would have
gone over I don't think it's got a great
deal but alright
okay what about flight square wise what
do I wouldn't do why is there a pause
here actually oh if the rook goes back I
just went upon all right I'll go pawn
hunting hmm I feel like I should get
more though let's go first flight Square
and negate this Knight f4 move I'm okay
with creating light square weaknesses
there's no light square bishop okay
that's the move I wanted to see cuz now
without this light square bishop around
for black this guy becomes enormous with
h6 g6 as a whole
oh no they just dropped tonight I missed
that I was on missed that I was on that
guy
let's return and mop some stuff
g6 is gonna collapse the skies in first
he's got 19 points rook is a goner okay
and they resigned all right I was there
I had a lot of games in there
all right there's 55 in here now see we
get next right
of real pawn first time playing against
real pawn
I write real pond let's try a five
mm-hmm okay let's begin with the Bishop
before I'm prepared to give up the
bishop for night you have to be if you
play this move all right there we go so
I'm playing against a structure opponent
has the bishops I'm gonna begin with
this I'm not sure if I want to play f5
Knight f6 yet so I'm gonna hold off for
just one move I don't want to play d5 d6
is in ok so right now I think I am
leaning more towards this the rooks need
to play at some point and this is going
to be the pawn break that brings both
rooks to life no I have an opportunity
to strand these two double isolated
pawns
that's fine and also this is fine so I'm
just going to develop and if ever a
capture I'm helped maybe at some point I
could capture here I think it's fine to
just go about it like this though puts
put my pieces on nice squares okay I
have enough file to work with all right
now do I want to gain some space
I am castled why does not do I have
anything against the King I think they
kind of just get out of that I'm gonna
go for some space hmm yeah let's try and
be annoying to this night
here it's unprotected might be
vulnerable a night here I'll probably do
this yeah let's do this
I guess the light square bishop SAR
gonna be off and if the light square
Bishop SAR often this could be a problem
that cannot be right there's no way not
castled and now the e-file is opening up
definitely not
all right
to check or not
wondering
well I think I'm starting to get fancy
that little nun over there he is a he's
unprotected that's kind of a weird
weird-looking move bishops under fire
and I put another one under fire Queen
h4 is pretty deadly and if the knight
moves f3 gets knocked out okay this is I
think this is just mate next regardless
of where the King goes Queen f2 is a TKO
I think that was a best move Knight e4
tactics unprotected night all right
we're caught the halfway point
I have 1619 1916 speedster right behind
a Powell all right see if we get next
Darkseid what was the opening we played
last ok let's try let's try b3 didn't
they go for a quick fee in Quetta
be three
all right let's go with Bishop b5 just
like in the last game I'm prepared to
give up the bishop for night and maybe
play against a structure yeah
night here black has to be careful of c5
and this is something I can target it as
a whole okay they're really gearing up
for a 5 I do not want to allow that type
of pawn presence by black upon trio if
this is in and then I played d4 then I
have to worry about e4 my knight has to
find a new home no I want to I want to
fight for e5 so there's a bit of black
was a bit inconsistent I believe I don't
think f6 was a good idea
let's castle can't do without that I'll
consider taking only after the bishop
has moved is now that time
hmm let's go
this here's the other thing if this pawn
ever captures here this would isolate
quite isolate this guy but can't feels
like a lot of stuff would be isolated I
think that Misha Piz just a tall pawn
how are these guys ever how's this pawn
ever going to move let's start with
Queen here seems purposeful to stare at
some weakened squares and also there's
this idea with this right the bishop
might be in some hot water suppose I
take here first and then take here next
isn't this a problem for block
is a super defender for my king so I
don't really have any worry of I don't
know something like this piece is
drifting over here okay so they saw that
they couldn't really wouldn't be a good
idea I think that's it's one of the
better moves so there is there is this I
think I want to I want to fight in the
center efore yeah now that I've taken
away from the center and this this could
be pretty good move and I probably want
to put pressure here if I do this I
think I get kicked around and then here
I have to watch about the changing of
the structure okay that move I don't
want the F file to open up so I guess
we're gonna start initiating some
exchanges I don't want to go too far
taking here extends the scope of that
Bishop this is probably blacks best
piece so my bishops not too bad either
though yeah I think I want to start with
this I am up upon I do have this square
to work with d6 so if I get a dark
square Bishop exchange drop a knight
right there things will be wonderful um
okay I don't like okay let's develop I
might have to work around a knight
enough for I think I could manage though
ah
[Music]
let's go like this I'm really I just
don't want to take here and help the
bishop out combined with the knight on
f4 it starts to be scary if two pieces
can coordinate on g2 one is annoying
enough I don't care about doubled pawns
this would give me access to this pivot
point on d6 okay and now there isn't
even a capture because there's a pin I
am way down on time once more maybe now
we take and then go here blockade make
sure this pawn doesn't move this Bishop
I want to play against and this I don't
want to see this move I'm trying to kill
off this bishop what's it's what's it
going to do gonna try for
some sacrifices over here yeah there it
is I forgot that that was even a move
is this okay Queen check there I want to
I want to do this probably should have
thrown a punch instead of this last move
but I think it's important to hang on to
this poem kind of watch out for the
unprotected stuff
my knight is hanging oh my god you have
to take like that
my knight is hanging
much time and I'm dropping upon uncle
this went wrong fast
I just want trade Queens can we have
that
we trade how to lose your whole kingside
in just three seconds this is okay all
right I think we're gonna try to win on
time try give me a square for my night
Oh got a queen I'm on the rook check her
oniy take a bishop where's the me Oh God
what's a disaster what happened there
ah man I mean I was the I was only
focused on a sacrifice on the other on
the other pond my each pawn forgetting
there was a sacrifice on that other guy
the F pawn okay biggie Errol is in first
with 32 I'm happy that my my bishop is
outside the pawn chain I'm not simple
person just want small small things here
that's all so this is this is welcome
wouldn't mind seeing a light square
bishop exchange are you gonna help me I
want to keep this tension because it's
difficult to complete development let's
just rule out that let's go here I guess
they're gearing up for a night here this
this is quite the traveler three moves I
that I will okay I think I need to start
securing some some squares over here
it's nice there's gonna be some pressure
against this guy I'm prepared to take
with the night okay this is this is a
wonderful improvement now to take or not
not I have this in mind after night
takes
it's tough to express but I have some
experience with this structure in the
end this is this is tipping in my favor
I haven't committed my king over here
this is another reason why this captures
available like if I was already castled
this is kind of scary so I'm ready to to
drop on in here do be have to be a
little bit careful rook here forgot that
that was even a move should be okay
though on on h4 knight on g6 I was going
to say rook here knight here there's a
tactic hmm well what's the story here
think I want it mmm do I want to take to
be a bit careful here huh
I'm not sure
let's take here mm-hmm
all right
I want to try and stir up trouble
against the king I take with the knight
that move okay let's let's hit my
opponent where they're a little bit weak
right here d4 is weak with that last
probe they're putting pressure on h4 got
rook here Queen here all my pieces may
be playing very soon with my king right
in the middle like my King is safer what
kind of production is this Bishop gonna
have okay Queen there I could take I am
on the Queen I do have the rook defended
let's actually take I'm okay if I
retreat here if they have to take with
the pawn that means my knight can rely
upon this square let's do this okay this
seems like a nice square what is it
doing exactly though let's make a move I
don't know let's go here rook rook c2
next maybe maybe hunt of the a pawn I'm
looking for this kind of move at some
stage just break the structure I think
this is too slow I have this covered in
case white wants to get some counter
play
extra peeling queen bee - pressure and a
lot of stuff what is she what is she not
attacking here follow-up rook see -
there's got to be something right around
the corner now I have all my pieces
playing white is on their back foot
they're on their back to ranks hmm what
do you do to defend e4 first and
foremost Bishop here I guess we go there
I have a check mm-hmm okay now is when
we break this Knight wants to play and
just want to move it I want a square
this nine I know five has to be
fantastic
watch out pieces on dark squares okay I
think we're close to giving checkmate I
have a little wall here can I get to the
the H file how can I get to the H file
fast
oh yeah yeah just just retreat just
retreat this is the only way I could
have done it
defending here now might miss that
where's the mate I got made soon King
move that's a mate listen don't ever do
what I just did there okay
there's something better Queen yeah I
have I have three moves I could afford
that sure Queen a three Queen f8 white
won't be able to defend in one move
yeah I didn't realize the Queen could
just pivot on the h-file and say no
you're not getting there I'm there first
15 minutes to go there right what do we
want to try I guess a English opening
well we'll see how it develops okay
let's grab some space I guess we have
now at Kings Indian let's try as a mesh
with
let's add some security to this weakest
point in my camp I'm gonna go here and
then this bot gonna give me a problem
blocking my queen
all right here we are to stop this or
not
I'm actually gonna take now and if this
I'm gonna try and clamp down and on that
move I feel like I miss played it uh
yeah just a hair or two let's try this I
want to watch out for the d5 move okay
hey now let's go here I'm opposite the
Queen
mmm that's giving up a really nice
square
it's my more important Bishop I don't
want to I want to give that up so easily
it's just babysit c4 I don't want to
jump in I want to maybe keep this open I
like seeing that move actually I got all
my pieces playing and I want to focus on
blacks weakest square now what would I
like to have happen here not sure I
could have these these pieces all
exchanged that might not be a bad thing
I could take here let's maybe threaten
to take
and then take upon is that too sneaky
um I guess will I
guess we'll jump in now take with pieces
yeah so rook here do I have anything
fancy going on along the D file not yeah
but I think it's close I want to go here
defend my bishop I think I might want to
do this oh that's not working though is
it
I have this counter sacrifice if this
this bishop here and if I back up I'm
gonna hang on to this guy's now right
yeah that's that's a connected passer
this rook moves this pawn Falls I'm
gonna hang on to this I don't want to
have to capture like this cuz this opens
up this diagonal towards my king
what diagonal not that one let's step up
this has to be useful he's happy he's
and he's on a light square now I have
chewed up a lot of time and now isn't
the rook is trapped isn't he to be
careful and he's short on squares so
takes and then here's the threat you
can't recapture like that and even if
the rook moves I take like this and if
this I enter okay that Bishop there or
yes very sensible okay very important I
think not to give up some type of dark
squares to my opponent
upon and I'm now going to be up to pawns
and I chop chop again with check and I
must have something juicy here
yeah they resigned chop chop here
probably takes takes and then
something there in the Queen Queen
specific endgame 36:28 I have maybe a
chance to catch up to that guy let's try
a Sicilian if I play fast enough see if
we could get a quick win in here okay
let's start with Queen c7 mm-hmm okay
not sure what I want to do with my
bishop just yet I'm not ruling out
hunting the h2 pond
I can't resist gotta get one game in
there or I do this pretty sure nose nose
all has seen me do this before like I
could do this see if my opponent is in
pre-move mode fancy okay I think this is
actually the best move
no it's not just a mate threat but they
takes bishop and it's uh it's a problem
so we're gonna take how I'm gonna go
with this because you know what white is
brewing and attack along the F file so I
want my queen defending in my Bishop to
see the world now I'm torn do I want to
put upon here to free my bishop or do I
want to do this and say my bishop is
fantastic on this square I'm gonna opt
for no no no no no there's that okay
we're gonna put the Bishop on e5 and be
satisfied
at the at the end there there isn't a
way to distract my queen away from
defending this pawn I could uh yeah I
don't know it's a bit too slow if I do
this trying to stop that then there's a
five a four you know I got to get some
more development in so this is a step in
the right direction let's put him right
here and how how do you get rid of this
massive bishop he is a five point piece
he so he probably do I fight off the
knight just take away squares from the
Knighton well actually what's wrong with
this open up the H file I'm not gonna
Cass on this direction what do you get
when you Castle King safety rook
activity I already have rook activity
not getting the full deal if I Castle
I'm demoting my rope if I Castle let's
take Queen takes okay I have this
covered you know forgetting all the
wonderful things this Bishop is doing
now this is probably a problem probably
a problem okay well how about we just go
here guard a lot of the squares along
the F file go here and think about this
that's all or even this
no no they're ready to contest me along
the H file I want to make sure I could
castle and fight there we go I like how
I'm playing it so far I
playing it so far is alright more
long-term I have the safer King to be
sure and well this is starting to look
okay oh this is what they have geared up
they're trying for that I guess but I'm
doing this to produce a square for my
bishop this is a nice diagonal bishop
pair the King doesn't know what color
complex is best he's he's unsure okay
well let's start with this let's see
what rook gets captured I think we both
do well to just keep the tension I'm
okay with going here I don't there's no
target okay the bishops gonna be demoted
okay this is where I could start to
break through I believe with ff5 let's
invite the bishop backwards first and
let's improve the Queen I don't think
that there's a great rush with this in
fact I give up a nice square to the
night maybe in some case I'm on the
bishop I am threatening this and then
that may be no because there's a
counterpunch against my bishop
I could try for here and then here I'm
no longer defending this once the night
moves
this was better okay now I do have a
check the Queen must block how about we
just give the knight a kick let's see
where the night goes first not up a pond
I am up on time though okay we're just
we're just going to defend this night is
now way off sides the night I was here
then I do this okay now I could give a
check check queen block but then there's
a Bishop takes pawn trying to distract
the Queen the King away from defending
the Queen and here there's this and
they're not playing that I have a check
could just exchange Queens let's go with
something simple let's kill the night
um
prove the king I'm dropping upon they're
dropping on time okay I might have to
try berserk game they go by performant
it goes by performance of a better
performance rating of a better
performance rating I think I'm gonna try
berserk
five minutes twenty seconds he's in a
game how is that one gonna turn out who
knows well what's what's the story it's
the night versus bishop ooh they just
play d5 the light squares are very
weekend g4 is probably good am I gonna
get a game okay black is allowed to
expand over here think white should have
clamped down mm-hmm he's gonna be intra
it's just ready to draw arrows come on
put me in a game 450 what's the time
situation I'm not sure it's not showing
there okay civil civil beast is the
likely last opponent let's see if I
could get a five big Errol all Big E
Errol needs is a draw and um I can't
catch the big guy okay let's see how
this pawn moves before moving my knight
he knows where he wants to be actually
he doesn't there are now two beautiful
squares this is it's not a good idea
this is this pawn is free but how is it
defended if I just add some more fuel to
it I might actually get a quick win here
they resign
I'm also threatening this would write
resign if I just go here I'm hitting
everything
threats when this pawn is here it's
important now to create this gap that's
a big problem now go for the exchange
I'll go for the exchange and we'll put
my other night here they resign with the
Beast resign should the Beast resign
let's see Queen Queen back home is the
only way to save let's go over here so
this is definitely the path you want to
go or the square you want to go to not
just because it's a reliable home but
also I want to look at getting a pawn
break in to put my extra rook to work
and f5 is the way that I could always
give him a shove or I could pick a pawn
up winning some stuff
and they take c4 I can return and maybe
I don't even need to play with that five
I could think about this some more
direct stuff okay now this is gonna fall
everything is dating back to the a4 move
Oh forgetting I went into berserk mode
they resigned back to tournament - Oh II
slipped opted he is we still that game
you know he lost that game oh okay let's
try one more one more berserk - well my
opponents my opponent had always known a
fry but I I have fire I have fire and I
have the the tiebreak on my side
can we get into a completely winning
position and see if Z Bob - is quick to
resign certainly a quick player
okay now oh now what's happening on
these dark squares I wonder about that
what's happening with this pawn
a back I'm winning the knight on c6 with
a resigned here 128 you have to press
this more go here defend and let's just
let's just keep going and take up on on
the night it could take a six a lot of
different things
it's just exchanged one minutes ago take
up on I just want to get rid of the
tricky night
there's probably mates probably made
soon oh very soon something happening
here and here that's actually mate next
move
Oh with 46 seconds to go in this game
this tournament is over tournament
pairings just closed okay was not
expecting to geta
that that last game in there okay how
many games total is that 11 I think
usually I get like nine in there alright
so
67 and all and this one all right very
nice for a late night tourney good games
to the 66 of you let's see the final
standings and the pages what do we get
we have page one big year all took
second nerve and Raymond ambitious
sociopath for Z Bob to speedster MTN
McAllister all right could see the rest
on page one I believe you could see the
rest
yeah that's all showing in the stream
oh it's glitching let's try a refresh
there we go page to the King checkmater
probably the one that subscribed and
messed up my my my layout on stream
gotta I gotta accommodate for those who
have like 17 characters in their name
anyhow these are all the pages and once
again good games all alright
you